bon il y a un médecin qui prend en
remplaçant pour remplacer une journée
puis le lendemain il arrive il lui
demande alors comment ça s'est passé
très bien enfin j'ai pas eu beaucoup de
clients je suis un truc qui avait mal à
la tête alors j'ai donné les cacher pour
et puis après j'ai un outil qui est
arrivé il avait envoyé il avait mal au
ventre je le détacher
puis après j'aimerais bien compris
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il y a une
femme qui est rentré très belle très
très belle très elle s'est déshabillée
complètement nue sur le complètement nu
bah alors qu'est-ce que tu as fait avec
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire qu'est-ce que
tu as vu qu'est-ce que tu lui as dit bah
je dis qu'est-ce qui vous arrive madame
ben j'ai pas vu un homme depuis 6
semaines
et alors tu as fait quoi tu as fait quoi
j'ai mis des gouttes dans les yeux
[Applaudissements]